[Music]
supposing you are one of the many
african-americans who feel that the
police one obvious sense of a source of
authority in society do not represent
your interest do not have your interests
at heart I'm not protecting you in your
community in an inner city in the United
States is that a form of authority which
they should be respecting and taking
account of or do they have a legitimate
legitimate case to say this is something
that is widely recognized as
authoritative but we don't feel it
should be for us well sure it's very
understandable but one has to understand
that I mean if I can back up to answer
the question that I reread recently
Lenin's attack on Rosa Luxemburg which
is called infantile leftism and I
realized that he was totally right and
Rosa Luxemburg was totally wrong it's a
life you've endorsed Leonard yes
but the point is that in the end you
need a party you need Authority you have
to work within a system of something and
there is a kind of infantile leftism
that talks about Authority in the way
Kafka talked about the castle there's a
thority there's the wall and we have
social movements where we come up and
we're ramming the door and every once in
a while
authority tosses things down to us right
that is not the way democracies work and
we cannot exaggerate the problems of
legitimacy in our democracies that know
there are doors into the earth into the
into the castle there are conversations
about how about things we might do
certain people have more voice than
others that's absolutely right but it is
not a wall and one consequence of
infantile leftism
is that in rejecting authority if it
throws itself into the hands of the
so-called people yeah and
populace Tribune yeah yeah that pretends
to speak for the P yeah yeah and there's
a long list of that beginning from the
Soviet Union down to Hugo Chavez and a
certain kind of infantile leftist that
falls in love with these truly
authoritarian figures because they're
against Authority well I agree with that
in part because indeed if you're going
to do politics by majority vote which
which which ends up with Chavez or herb
on this this this fellow in in Hungary
as an example or god help us Donald
Trump that's where you're appealing
would not you but one is appealing to a
majority rule we vote and then the
minority is crushed you jail your
political opponents and so forth but
there's a third way which is not
infantile it's an optimism about
self-organizing humans free humans and
indeed as an economist of course I'm
very enthusiastic about this notion that
a market society doesn't need massive
walls massive authorities castles
telling them what to do I think you're
right that if you take the political
view of naive democracy you're going to
get naive results are great journalists
in the United States and the early 20th
century
HL Mencken said democracy is the theory
that the common people know what they
want and deserve to get it good and hard
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you